thank you christina thank you for
[Music]
hosting me here hosting this talk it's a
great pleasure so i'm going to talk
about
provide you an overview of the research
on affective technologies particularly
well-being and mental health that i have
done with my research group and network
of collaborators pretty much over
spend years now looking back
and ethics is very relevant for this
topic and it's gonna be a red thread
throughout my presentation and here now
i'm gonna emphasize the ethical aspects
of the work that we have done
so about three years ago we completed a
systematic review of hdi work on
affective systems we pretty much look
back at previously 10 years published
papers in sikhi proceedings and we
targeted systems built around three
affected disorders stress bipolar
condition and depression because these
are the most prevalent and the most with
the highest societal impact
and
findings have shown that hci space
here is start getting mostly data-driven
systems
uh focusing on sensing collecting
displaying data to support self-tracking
and diagnosis of these conditions
in contrast there is less work focusing
on clinical interventions and those are
targeting mostly cpt structural
interventions such as computerized
cognitive behavioral therapy biofeedback
interventions and mindfulness so there
are pockets of work starting to grow the
growth in this field i have to reassure
you is exponential so it's going to be
far more coming up as we as we move
towards future
um ethics it's clearly an important
topic of what i'm talking about today so
i'm going to try to tell you it's also a
key part of our findings we have a
section of ethics alone
two-thirds of these papers just remember
these are papers looking at affective
disorders right do not mention ethics
right
and those that do the other third are
focusing primarily on the autonomy
principle this is about respecting users
choice ability to make choices and
consent
and
non-maleficence principle which is about
not harming
so
we look at these papers look how they
deal with the different ethical
principles and try to articulate some of
the best practices that are emerging in
the field
so first diagnosis can be highly
problematic
right it perpetuates stigma but more
importantly
when provided without support for
therapeutic assistance can really
backfire you leave somebody with a
diagnosis of depression could be hugely
problematic for any self-help apps
second logging personal data can improve
the accuracy of the diagnosis and also
personalization of the treatment
but issues of data ownership are huge in
this space
third
involving users is key to support
autonomy
and a voice to ensure that their voice
is being heard but at the same time
highly vulnerable users might benefit
from screening because engaging in
research can be might be detrimental to
wear health to their health so this is a
very important finding
and finally finally there is an
abundance of data on social media on
public public sites but harnessing the
data secondary research data for
research could also be problematic
because issues of consent can still
raise and
i think as researchers should be mindful
if you try to extract the data
it's very easy to de-identify
participants
right with respect to affective health
technologies
we also looked at how user acceptance
and long-term use can be better
supported
this is important given that digital
interventions require a little bit of a
longer term use and discontinuing the
app before the end of the interventions
might be actually detrimental to people
so what did we do in order to help
designers think for long-term acceptance
of health technologies
we developed tact toolkit which just got
accepted at kai we're very happy at best
paper award as well
it's a design tool to support reflection
on user acceptance
and also how this acceptance evolve
through user journey
and this is very interesting and user
journey can start even before we engage
with the technology could be a pre-use
stage when we
explore ask advice contemplate and
select a specific technology then we
have initial acceptance usually the
first week of years this could make or
break
our engagement with stack
but then we also have sustained
acceptance which goes from over a month
to even below further down over a year
of use so you can see these are very
important stages within user acceptance
each of them as i would tell you on the
next slide involves different set of
factors involved
shaping the acceptance
so the technology acceptance toolkit
consists of 16 cards
three personas
three temporal multi-choice scenarios
a virtual think space and a website from
where the cards can be fully downloaded
to design the tag cards
we critically reviewed
there is a rich space of
literature on user acceptance and we
selected and operationalized some of the
valid models for user acceptance
we also included our own technology
acceptance
life life cycle that we published in the
gmail paper a bit earlier where again we
try to bring forward this temporal
dimension of user acceptance and provide
a more consistent terminology because
the terms are used so interchangeably
the same term with different meanings
that the space is quite conceptually
quite messy so we try to bring a little
bit of conceptual clarity here
so from these models uh we extracted 16
key factors impacting acceptance
and design one card for each of these
we also organize them in three color
coded categories health for uh in red
individuality and social so social
aspects in
orange and technology in blue and we
evaluated the toolkit with 21 digital
health designers through workshops
and findings showed that
acceptance which is rather of abstract
concept we know that from all the work
we've done with literature review
it became far more accessible to the
designers through use of the cards
concrete and accessible
expanding the awareness of the different
factors that might be relevant
also from them to think about future
acceptance future future use of the tech
and we really this is where they really
challenge we think about how this tech
will be used six months from now a year
from now and i think we can really
benefit from additional designs methods
or tools to support that future thinking
and of course you can borrow from the
existing pockets of work
speculative design and future thinking
design but something of that could be
really is really needed for this
long-term acceptance designing for
long-term acceptance
so emphasizing again it is this back of
temporal perspective which i think makes
this paper quite unique and really
needed because often we design for a
situated interaction
but don't have this unfolding
temporality in our mind
so now i will illustrate uh some of our
work we've done on emotional awareness
technologies
uh through three we call them design
examples they are really three points
within the broader design space i chose
them so i hope they can inspire you and
provoke your thinking
and i will start with the affective
health system this involves a galvanic
skin response which measures skin
conductance or perspiration and a wealth
of research has shown that it's
associated with increase of
physiological arousal and therefore we
can say with also our in more intense
emotions speed than positive or negative
um
i did this study is published in 2019
but we did it quite a few years earlier
weren't many wearable devices at the
time we use a philips
wristband which has gsr sensors within
and this has been connected to a mobile
app where we had some very beautiful
visualizations of physiological arousal
shown in real time also historically you
can look and browse back
and
there is a spiral shape which
which has a chronology on it and you
have colors of red mapped to high
arousal and something in the green uh
side of the color spectrum which mapped
lower hours people can make annotations
and so forth
and we evaluated this system with 23
participants who use it for a month
and
as they were learning to make sense of
their gsr data now gsr sensors is a new
technology for a company for instance
with high rate monitors that most people
are more familiar with so it took time
for them to try to understand what the
system's showing them
and we call this a proto practice a
newly emerging practice
and
these ambiguous representations that
have been shown to them we found that
people interpreted them in different
ways
subject to what matters in their lives
so some of them did it for stress
management other did it for performance
some of them were athletes
um performance monitoring and others did
it just for pure light locking
so our conclusion here is that if we are
designing and evolving
we don't involve a well-established
practice but it's a proto-practice like
making sense of just our data a more
open ambiguous design is useful allowing
people to project the meanings that are
relevant to them
it's likely that when a more specific
meaning is identified then i think we
have to play with the ambiguity a little
bit more carefully right as a design
principle but at this stage it felt
it felt right
moving away from traditional screen
interfaces we did quite a bit of work
with small materials now i don't know
maybe many of you have heard they are
growing the interest in small materials
is growing in hci's
community we borrow a lot of material
sciences i think they are very
interesting materials they bring forward
a different range of constraints and
affordances and as designers make us
think deeply about our assumptions
because you operate is something that
it's not you don't find it in screen
based interfaces
so similar to affective health systems
we system we also use gsr sensors here
um
and
but we focus explicitly on the
exploration of a broader range of
actuators we want of course it's not
just visual
but we also work with haptics and i'm
going to show you our exemplars
so um
first of all i'm starting with some
visual smart material interfaces this
involves thermochromic paints
so these are materials which become
actuated by heat there is a heating
layer under them then you have an
insulation layer and you can have it on
your skin
um they can be flexible in different
sizes you can put them on your wrist you
can put them on your
body on your clothes you can put them on
your shoes people our participants did
all kind of crazy stuff with them
and the two prototypes i'm showing here
uh provide again some abstract on the
ambiguous representations of changes of
arousal the first one i'll show you my
video my
if it's working
ah it's working so you can see how it
actuates now i'm going to start the
bottom one so the first one is showing
increases in arousal reflected in colors
changing from blue and green to red
and the second one is changing from
purple to pink the heating layer beneath
is shaped in different ways as a spiral
on the top and as a heart on the bottom
so therefore the visualization resembles
those shapes
and you can see they are slow right now
this lowness it's a very important
design quality which we wouldn't have
thought about if we did if we work with
effective
screen based interfaces which are very
responsive right and it's a quality that
we bear in mind in the future designs
and we evaluated this with six
participants in the lab that were just
low level prototypes but people liked
people like the ambiguity and they also
like this slow change of colors which
unfolds in front of their eyes they
really like that very much someone has
very aesthetic qualities almost like a
performance they were captivated
but they would also have liked to have
control over the colors we chose this
thermochromic paint very carefully to
map red with intense arousal and green
blue with low arousal but in practice
actually they would have liked to take
the prototypes and use them but they
said i would like to use them
conspicuously in public i don't want
people to
understand that i'm stressed if the
device becomes red so they wouldn't like
to work with socially loaded color
meanings
and this is something again we remember
later
then we continue developing additional
prototypes six more involving both
visual the first three and haptic
actuators
um
i'm not gonna insist much on the visual
but just the the second one is quite
interesting here we played with three
colors rather than just two and showed
map red to high arousal yellow to middle
arousal so we came with the middle level
of arousal which actually proved to be
quite useful and blue to low arousal
and then the last three are haptic they
are really wristbands
one consists of mini vibration models
which vibrate when the arouser is high
one is a shape memory alloy which gently
squeezes a hand
when the arousal is high and the other
one is a flexible conductive fiber which
generate worms again when the arousal is
high so they are all
designed in order to prompt emotional
awareness
so we evaluated them with 12
participants using them for a couple of
days and again this was outside of the
lab
and follow up with interviews and our
findings show that
their value in supporting people
understand their emotional responses and
also developing awareness for effective
chronometry this is a concept from
psychology and is really understanding
how emotions unfold in time the
physiological arousal raises and decays
and each emotional experience we have
has this has a signature of some sort
sometimes can be speak some parts
sometimes can increase lower other
slower pace but
we have this and
we've even haven't built these slow
visual visualizations using
thermochromic paints particularly
this affected chronometry
awareness would not have been will not
be able to capture
so
an important finding is a display made
people pay attention in the moment of
how they felt it's very hard to ignore
them
particularly the particularly the uh
haptic ones because you don't
necessarily have to look at them right
but they look at visual ones as well
um and they also supported the
interpretation of arousal at the
beginning people associated discrete
emotions with this displays which is of
course this is not what they represented
they represented arousal but towards the
third day
most of them managed to decouple the
arousal
from the balance right so an intense an
actuation means high arousal this is a
very important because we really
challenge our four psychology of our
models we don't think about emotions in
terms of complex models that took on two
dimensions arousal and violence but we
talked about in terms of discrete
emotions but these usability prototypes
really allow them to understand this
distinction very viscerally
and the color display involving three
colors was very helpful to help them
develop this clarity this disambiguation
from discrete into the space of arousal
alone
in contrast to visual displays the
haptic ones
were perceived as more embodied they
were really touching the skin in a way
that affected the visual one didn't and
the gradual increase in temperature was
very expressive and quite hedonic
qualities so again it's something we
bear in mind in future work
so we took home from here four design
implications
emotional skill for our well-being this
is when we try to realize something in
your life am i trying to do something to
better regulate our emotions
and this slow change that never comes
from support users to hold their
attention on their displays
also the slowness encourages reflection
and again the temporal lobby that is
shown motivates people to fall and
people are aware of their technology
and finally we are looking for the value
of expressivity uh representing
emotional states and again using quick
algorithm to
[Music]
so after we built these smart prototypes
we they constructed them
and put together
two this one's intended to support
novice users to build their own
personalized affirmative displays
and
addresses the need for personalization
that we've seen in our clients
of course we're also trying to borrow a
little bit comfortable we work in hci on
diy and maker movement and
democratization technology making and we
are aimed to do all of those things as
well
so um
also most of the other displays have
outlet boxes so opening them up and
allowing people to work with them could
be quite difficult for experimental
models behind the stack and
they support as i said specialization
but also agency adoption and also
retargeting display as we also found in
our clients ikea
consisting of digital and traditional
materials and allowed people to include
this hyped product in the building
heating materials on the top right
gsr sensors and the connectors on the
bottom left
insulation material in the bottom needle
and supporting tools like paint brushes
paint spreader for applying the plain
syringes and so forth on the bottom
right
and we explore the toolkits we against
record design workshops with 20
participants 11 where males 9 females
with no expertise in bio sensors
and each workshop consists of
of three sessions
first we ask them to sketch
representation of emotional arousal
using paper and advanced scholars
then we introduce them to the kid and
and they explore the key just to
understand how the materials work and
then we are going to build the
prototypes based on the sketches they
done in the first session
in this part we also gave them um
expose them to a set of images arousal
interviews this is how they perceive the
experience of working with the kids and
the design of the of their designs and
the use of the prototypes
so a very important one is that despite
the limited studies all participants
were able to design and successfully
build their devices
it allowed people also to use the body
in the design body would have to be used
we elicited the outer using the pictures
but they also tried to try to get
themselves excited or to call it
ourselves to move around to activate the
prototypes through their body so body of
the element development in the design
came forward from these findings um and
of course personalization was shiny bro
fine we were very delighted to do that
and about the creative expression that
they you know they're making this
advertise allowed
um this is an important outcome because
most of the toolkits in the diy
literature talks about people assembling
stuff but here was not just assembling
they had this creative expression that
came through as well
a key finding is that there are two
distinct motivations for designing such
interfaces
somebody's even did it for awareness of
emotions for example they use
predominantly red colors under shape
um
because it was increased arousal right
and
the other other set of participants they
did for emotional population they use
more soft colors soft patterns
blue or green colors and more round
shapes
and i'm also going to say these two
motivations were very gendered
and the toolkit was used to design
effective interfaces for these two
different purposes emotional awareness
and emotional modulation
but you could also build them for both
you can have two displays that are the
same materials supporting both both
distributions those are key for
emotional well-being
a very cool one is for how both
awareness revolution can be supported
through through the same kind of
technology
um and this is this is the key outcome
of worldwide
another implication is that
um
by explaining experimenting with the
toolkit participants developed at this
restriction understanding of their
arousal and decapitated from the
violence
so people develop attachment to these
prototypes which um and would have liked
to take them through them in daily life
which is a very nice outcome right so um
i talked about emotional awareness
couple of prototypes we built and now
i'm going to move forward towards a more
exciting space emotional regulation this
is a little bit more challenging
and although
effective interfaces supporting
emotional awareness
also allow people to self-regulate like
the the one that i've shown they kind of
realize oh this is hierarchy i came and
i came from from a meeting with my
supervisor maybe i can try to do
something to lower my browser and see
what's happening let me breathe they did
a bit of that but the device wasn't
purposefully tailored to support
self-regulation of effect and this is
something we tried to do through this
body of work and here we use a range of
technologies we use again wearables we
use 3d printed food very interestingly
we look at mobile apps of different
sizes and we also looked at wall size
displays
so i will start with thermochromic and
vibra thermal and vibrotactile
interfaces
so
building on user strong preference for
personalization of affected interfaces
we started this this work by looking at
uh how we can co-design affect
regulation technologies uh that are
personalized by people right
and um
in terms of the modality we choose to go
with haptic
haptic patterns which we have seen that
are more embodied
and also do not demand visual attention
which is key in everyday life
right um and therefore
we thought would be a good starting
point
and for this we
we conducted a study which consisted of
two parts
in the first part we gave to our haptic
group two commercial devices
uh they are wrist worn devices one that
provides precise localized thermal
sensations the top image and another one
which provides
vibrations the bottom image
and each haptic actuator
was connected to a mobile interface
application and participants could
explore it and also change the actuators
parameters
it wasn't a vast design design space
they they have one or two choices but
definitely was a sense of
personalization that came forward so
people could vary temperature from
minus
11 to plus 16 degrees celsius from their
body temperature
and they can also vary vibration
frequency
from 30 to 185 bits per minute and
vibration intensity from 5 to 100 more
in the second part of the study the
haptic group received the personalized
patterns that they have created for each
for themselves
um
during a stressor task we give them a
very well defined stressor task from the
literature and the control group which
did not design not receive any haptic
patterns were still exposed to the same
stressor
and we collected self-measurements of
anxiety using an event
stake questionnaire state trait anxiety
inventory and we also capture hrv data
and a range of metrics around that to to
identify the level of stress and then we
continue with interviews with the haptic
group to see how they design the
patterns and how they perceive the value
of the partners doing the stressor task
now overall
the findings show that the haptic
patterns be them fiber tactile or
thermal
significantly lower the the stress level
um through both objective and subjective
measures of stress for the haptic group
compared to the to the control group
so um
for vibrotactical patterns most
participants created low frequency
vibrations of 30 bits per minute
rather than high frequency one you know
we have two but i think that'll be more
of an exception and also associated them
with a heartbeat
we didn't tell them they resonate with a
heartbeat but they are with lower heart
rate and they also thought that this low
frequency vibration would represent a
slow target heart rate when they need to
calm down as shown in this illustrative
quote
i went for the lowest 30 bit per minute
actually they would have gone even lower
if the system would have allowed them
i could get the reason is that i felt
slower it was nicer to come down at a
slow rate rather than when it's really
high
that is like more panicky
only two participants did not associate
the vibration with heart rate but they
still appreciate the slow rhythm
for the thermal patterns
things are a bit more more diverse half
of participants designed to increase the
temperature between 2 to 10 degrees more
than their body temperature
and they refer to this pattern as warm
they didn't want it too hot but worms
was good worm was quite hedonic
um comforting resembling the human touch
as we see in the first quarter it feels
like someone is holding your hand
we had this expectation as a design
stage it's nice to see that it came
through the findings
other half of participants designed
their patterns by decreasing the
temperature from minus eight to minus 11
degrees now this was very interesting
they leverage very common metaphors of
cooling yourself down again they didn't
like heat and they also thought that
coolness is a bit more
standing out noticeable and because it's
lacking familiarity we don't really have
we have worms but we don't have cool so
often on our wrist
and
i will just conclude with a couple of
implications that came from this study
so first we highlight
the value of supporting implicit affect
regulation this is involving unconscious
cognition and no specific action through
the entrainment this is the entrainment
of slow bodily rhythms such as those of
heartbeat entrained by the vibration
that they felt on the wrist
such binary slow rhythms
can be super supported by activation
patterns like we've seen through the
vibration
but we can also work with entrainment
from other modalities you can think of
visual or sound that is pulsating in a
specific rhythm right so we can do
entrainment in different modalities
and even through other haptics through
modalities like turmoil and this is very
interesting because thermal didn't let
to entrainment it wasn't the rhythm
there but it was hedonic and embodied
and therefore we can think now why not
in a way integrate them and
add the the to the to the
worms or coolness let them move in some
rhythmic 30 bits per minute and in a way
add entrainment quality to already
hedonic important quality of the haptics
and i think that would be a very
fascinating future research direction to
marry the benefits of two modalities
that we just discussed to haptic
modalities
and also participants
would have liked to
have more dynamic patterns to respond to
the different stress levels during the
stressor task it was just a path in the
design and we used it throughout
throughout the entire uh stressor task i
think it took about 10 minutes for them
and they said oh no we'd have like this
to change if you're at low level or
increasing level high level so that was
interesting that people would like that
to be personalized and adaptive as well
3d printed flavors
now
we looked at food as a resource for
design
many reasons why food well first of all
is very emotional it's very sensorial uh
body is really shining in most of my
work so we could not look at food and
also has been historically used
tremendously for emotional regulation so
this is part of a larger project where
we look at exploring eating experiences
and actually we can we just completed a
systematic review of over 100 papers in
human food interaction
from the lens of eating experiences and
here i can tell you that there is an
emerging trend a move from
moving from taste stimulation towards
multi-sensory flavor stimulation right
so we want far more modalities engaging
this in these things
see more modalities being engaged in
this body of work and it's not just for
stimulation but also for sensory
deprivation so we're trying to see how
you can switch off and on some of the
senses
um so this is what this body and one
more thing this body of work also starts
to show an increasing interest of
in two noble sites for interaction that
i think as a community are very exciting
to explore is the mouth and the viscera
that got us new sites of interaction and
with the advent of
ingestible sensors i think this is going
to be very very promising in the near
future
so
in order to explore this i'm just going
to throw in one another i think it's a
it's a neat research tool that we
develop we call it sensory food probes
um to support
people become more aware of their eating
experiences and we use this in a diary
study with five romantic couples
and consists of a set of objects on the
right hand side
for sensory augmentation and deprivation
blindfolding and gloves and nose clip uh
but also a board game where we have
evocative pictures it's it's a board
game that the two the people in a couple
can work with each other can play they
associate food with different elements
on the board and they have uh they were
designed a way they are provoking
resonate with some aspects of flavor
experience and so forth
so i'm not going to insist on this i
just show you that this is what we did
with these five couples for about two
weeks with a diary study and after
they've been sensitized to these
experiences we engage with them in a
co-design of flavors
and we want them to design five flavors
three of them to express emotions like
uh
happiness sadness and an emotionally
neutral one such as expressions such as
say hi
and we also wanted from them to design
two flavors for co-regulation of effect
to calm down their partner and to cheer
them up
and once they designed this with us then
the first author
prepared the samples
the flavors and iterated with them with
each participant individually so they
are they are as they should be
and then in the third stage of the study
we deploy these flavors
together with a
small 3d food printer in participants
home and let them use them as they would
like for a couple of days and then we
follow up with interviews
so the 3d printed flavors supported
expressivity physicality playfulness
joint action and gift giving these are
all strategies for
connectedness right
in terms of the regulation cheering up
was mostly mostly used and predominantly
through chocolate based
flavors i mean not surprisingly
we have strong chocolate for strong
preference for chocolate as a comfort
food and inducing pleasure
calming down was supported far more
through more diverse flavors
predominantly juices and teas
but finding all together showed the
value of these 3d printed flavors for
two important intimacy rituals end of
day and the evening meal
and in the paper we discussed the
lengths
how our findings support
people to really reflect not only on
remember but also imagine flavored
positive flavors they didn't try to
create flavor for negative experiences
and how such flavors can be integrated
in these focal intimacy practices to
support emotional co-regulation
we also look at digital well-being
uh and how behavior regulation of
limiting phone overuse can be better
designed for
now as you are probably fully aware
there is a massively growing space of
digital commercial digital well-being
apps
um but they have been limitedly explored
academically uh so we completed a recent
functionality review of 39 most popular
digital wellbeing apps from google play
but we also reviewed with the same
coding scheme 17 apps developing and
describing academic work so i think this
work is quite quite
extended
and finally show that
apps focus mostly these apps digital
welding apps focus mostly on limiting
screen time
and these apps are doing this through
four interventions
creating obstacles to limit use very
common just plot your phone
or app
supporting awareness
of reaching the set limits this is
usually done through notifications
supporting motivation to keep within set
limits this is done often through
gamification principles
and supporting focus attention away from
the phone through some interventions but
they are not really super exciting
pretty much for example white noise
right so just focus on something else
and not many of them are doing that so
this work led to several design
implications they are
unpacking the paper quite extensively
but here i'm just gonna mention one key
key one so for us the most important is
that the current problematic emphasis on
these apps on limiting use
limiting smartphone news
we think that this reflect this this
does not reflect the rich body of hdi
we're coming on um supporting more
mindful user technologies
and this can i think this should mark a
shift
from addressing a problematic behavior
by explicitly limiting it
but rather by supporting more meaningful
use of smartphones so moving from
avoidance to approach motivation is
surely a better way to deal with this
challenge
and of course there is a massively
growing body of organ hdi on mindfulness
technologies i i work on that space as
well it's not part of this talk actually
it was a bit touching yesterday talk two
days ago talk um and i think that
there's really ripened to be to be
leveraged for something like that to
support better interaction with
smartphones
and more meaningful pursuits why not
um
right so i'm going to talk a little bit
about commercial depression apps so
depression was really a key aspect of
of some of my work so we look at that
from the perspective of commercial apps
and i'm going to give you a couple of
studies we analyze depression apps
this is one study we completed content
analysis of depression up descriptions
on marketplaces over 300 such apps
and the findings show that
the most of these apps focus on multiple
disorders depression is something
as often anxiety
and therefore they focus on trans
diagnostic interventions and also focus
on multiple theories so it's quite a
high aim right
more importantly while many
interventions appear to be this evidence
informed they were they were issued with
research evidence and fit with clinical
guidelines
rather concerning
we did not find any app to fully align
with treatments their treatments with
clinical guidelines that is really
really concerning
so we suggested developers uh a set of
we provided a set of reflective
questions to suggest developers how we
can approach this design a little bit
better looking at multi-disciplinary
collaborations to produce clinically
valid effective and safe treatments for
their patients um
we ask them to to reflect on the skills
and expertise around the table that they
are working with
to provide these rationale for that for
their interventions and of course be
more sensitive towards the issues of
safety and duty of care for the users
towards users
we also looked beyond app descriptions
analyzed users reviews of apps for
depression so this paper just got
accepted that kai
and we
did automatic analysis conducted
automatic analysis of over 2000 user
reviews sampled from 40 depression apps
from both google play and apple store
and users reported both positive and
negative experiences and some of them
with strong ethical implications
i'm going to highlight here some of the
key risks that we identify was potential
for misdiagnosis
and harmful advice that people receive
especially through peer support these
findings were really really concerning
and are very strong
also concerning was the vast amount of
data about usability of the apps we are
in a space space where we're designing
for experience but the apps develop for
people with mental health conditions
such as depression still have many of
them serious disability issues
all kind of issues this was
really really in a way unexpected i know
there is a lot of pressure to put
updates at the abs earlier maybe before
they are robust but um it could be very
problematic for vulnerable people like
those with depression because they
cannot continue treatment for example
um concerns about app validity safety
and accuracy also raised
with respect to the design of the
intervention and design of the app
itself the interface design as well
so we organize these elements within the
frame within a framework integrating
biomedical and virtual ethics
so with respect to autonomy an important
design implication was that it's
important to support users to choose
their apps treatment options in-app
options and to be able to customize
and more broadly for the developers to
listen to their voice some of them did
these user reviews rich developers and
they did changes based on those but not
all the time
with respect to access we need to better
leverage users preference for such apps
over world real world care this was
another important finding
in terms of the commerce we refer here
to ups cost business models and consumer
rights
this was one of the most passionately
discussed theme
in user reviews
they expressed very strong views about
how these apps many of them should be
free
and very interestingly
we didn't see many concerns with respect
to privacy and respect for diversity so
there is very limited aware that even
free apps that in fact are not free they
don't really realize that
um and then issues of trust transparency
were raised by about a quarter of the
reviews
mostly about insufficient going back to
the commerce model ups cost treatment
processes you you get to use an app and
then additional costs are used for
hidden for functions which were not
revealed at the beginning which which
users need and that was really really
upsetting when after they already start
using the app for a while
um
so
so what is really needed here is more
honest transparent description of apps
cost
financially or otherwise even if in
terms of personal data
and also reviewers like the fact that
there is a social impact that is apps
for reducing stigma and normalizing
mental health care they appreciated that
and finally with respect to depression
apps
we
explore 29 top apps for depression
through a review of their key
functionalities tracking screening
provision of interventions and here we
found that most apps friendly fresh
depressionist lack of well-being so not
really a very robust way to frame
depression and
diagnosis was again very problematic
because many of these apps use
non-validated screening tools
and there is again limited evidence to
do that
and also most of these apps are already
suitable for children
but where really they
they did not provide any policy
consistent with the rating of being used
being being adequately for children
other ethical concerns include for
example the the sharing of suicidal
thoughts uh
like high highly negative content and
limited support for suicidal risks again
especially for those apps which allow
this sharing
and a design implication we argue for
the importance of safeguarding users
while accessing and consuming negative
content and again sell select
age-appropriate apps support is needed
for that
and also most apps capture mood or
thoughts but honestly together i think
integrating these two things are very
important and also we suggest
integrating this track content with the
progress made through the intervention
so people can see how the moodle track
is is is reflected
mapping their engagement in the
intervention and motivate them to
continue with the intervention
and the very last part we saw a bit of
work in the space of dementia this is
part of a larger project where we
investigated how people living with
dementia can be supported through
increased stimulation and again we start
to look beyond screens beyond
particularly small screens that have
been often used in dementia care and
look for something noble and this is how
you build dementia wall this is a
prototype consisting of nine high
quality displays arranged in an l-shaped
grid which we deploy for over a year in
a residential care home
we found significant engagement and
adoption of the of the prototype which
was extensively used i'm not sure how
many of you work in pervasive system
area as well well i can tell you that
public displays are uh are really
challenging in terms of long-term
engagement uh and the way that this this
study show that was particularly
relevant and useful was really really a
little bit different than the body of
work we already seen and this is because
we employ a very co-participatory
research method the staff staff here uh
in the house took ownership of supplies
and really use them the way they see it
fit for their residents
and they actually generated four new
psychosocial interventions inspired by
the dementia wall supporting sensory
emotional cognitive and social
stimulation for the elderly this
stimulation is very important so one
such example for example for instance is
bringing the life no longer accessible
to these residents some of them
most of them advance dementia uh
allowing them to experience these things
very dear to them like for example a ch
a math in a church
um
another important one i'm just going to
highlight now is
intervention for mood and behavior
regulation using nature inspired media
this is this content you know seascapes
and forest landscapes were sourced
online by the care staff and who took
very active role to select the content
curated for the specific needs in a
moment of their residence
video of sunny beaches and waves
breaking gently were particularly useful
supporting people to
handle their agitation which is very
high especially at night so we have this
very powerful quote with dementia there
is a lot of walking
so that one resident for example almost
exhausts herself but with the right
image she would relax almost
instantaneously shoulder would drop and
she would sit and look at the screen
the display was so used that even after
a year we decided we have to leave it in
it was quite expensive but became part
of the
the home care fabric of life would have
been unethical to remove and i is still
being used now several years later
so this is what i have to say i just
want to thank thanks my fantastic phd
students uh the first three of them on
the top line have graduated in the last
year camille has survived attending andy
on his writing up and some of my amazing
academics that i've been working with
over the last i don't know 10 years or
so
thank you very much i'm happy to take
questions
[Applause]
well i'd like to
ask something earlier you said
that it was highly gendered um
could you return back to that piece
because that was sort of like a little
dangling tease yeah
yes um
all female participants went for
straight effect regulation
all male participants weren't for effect
awareness very interesting that is very
interesting okay
i had a quick question about like the
earlier part of your presentation where
you talked about
you know using gsr sensors and giving
sort of feedback about the state of
arousal um i was wondering how accurate
these sensors were and in cases when if
they were not accurate and you know like
my device told me that i was aroused
when i was not how would i react to that
what was
doing
yeah
good question of course they are not
they are wearable sensors they are not
lap sensors and we also have a little
bit of delay we take about five seconds
with time window to get the response so
they are in a moment but and some
emotions are very very fleeting so
that's a very good question
but you know
people experimented with them a lot they
try to understand the meaning they put
them on the windshield they start to run
with them i don't know if some of them
showers with them they're all kind of
moving hands they tried to make the
sense and
sometimes meaning could have been
portrayed when the data was inaccurate
um but what was important is that
towards the end of the study which was
just couple of days they did the couple
so i think the we don't really we work a
lot with biomedical engineers and signal
processing people in in our project i
didn't put here acknowledgement yeah
anyway but this is part of a big
european funded project um and they are
very going for the whole grain i think
in hci we have to be more tolerant about
the the robust not about the the pure
accuracy of our data yeah it it was
enough to provoke and if they couldn't
make sense actually some of them trusted
the display others started to trust
their feelings a little bit more which
is also another positive thing so i
think it's an interesting issue about
locus of control there
we have a question
sure
i study wearable and lead an initiative
at stanford around wearable
so thank you so much professor tess for
your very engaging talk and
i i wonder if you could please share
your thoughts about using vr
virtual reality for affect control
thank you i think that's a very good
question very very timely and topical
question um i have to say i
did to engage with vr uh feels like
another time during my phd i moved away
from vr for different reasons but it's
coming very very strongly for that i
think we just put another european beat
using vr for for for emotion regulation
i think
there is a lot of potential um
i mean of course you can leverage lots
of aspects of er sense of presence
immersion um and
particularly i think
it would be nice to see how it can be
used for materializing emotional states
in a physical form that we can play with
them tangently i really really this is
my i really like to leverage vi
not because of its inherent qualities
that you can do anything you can do
coaching all but what can be very good
for emotional regulation i think this is
a really interesting space otherwise it
provides a functionality that might not
be better than what zoom provides that's
what i'm always thinking what how how
clever design has to be done to address
a problem in a very novel way and i
think this materialization of emotional
states that we can
we process and change by interacting
with them i don't know as avatars or
whatever i think would be quite powerful
does it answer your question
oh yes thank you so much yeah i can i
can get several ideas from your answer
about maybe different avatars of animals
or people or just creative settings that
might help people
what do you want something
well i'd like to know a little bit um
your comment about uh apps for
depression it's
a little obvious you think about it but
then the consequences are utterly
terrifying do you have thoughts about a
better way to approach the situation
i think there are lots of pools
outside of academic realm i think we
might try to engage as policy makers
this is happening a little bit in the uk
actually dion is working for nice which
is
setting standards for actually she was a
student actually who's working on ethics
and most of the work on digital uh
on on apps for depression their ethics i
think
uh regulating to some sense i know there
are no medical devices but there is a
sense of some additional regulation
should come in we don't want to distract
self-help but not necessarily for people
who are already highly vulnerable like
people with depression diagnosis now of
course some people can have depression
diagnosis without being actually
diagnosed and not navigate towards these
apps
but i think clear clear clarity for what
kind of users they these apps are
suitable for what kind of views are not
suitable this is not currently being uh
explained on the marketplace i think the
marketplace should have clears i think
we provide this in a paper clear
structure of how these apps are
uh the information is provided so they
have comparison across
um so yeah i think i i there is no clear
solution we really have to engage with
policy makers i think if we work in this
space
and i apologize i would ask a follow-up
because uh you speak a little fast i've
missed
as do i i've missed uh
your explanation about why sending them
to friends was problematic
well peer peer support your support peer
support
is often
it could come from a good place but
doesn't have the necessary skill to
communicate what needed communicating so
could be judgmental it happened
people might even feel harassed
bullied so some of the quotes were
really really scary this was a very very
sad unsurprising finding that we find
and i really have to highlight it here
so the paper is not presented yet but
yeah we'll be
will highlight that kai
let's go
i did have one more question i'm trying
not to talk you
fine so um
you said of course we need more policy
changes with the apps in the marketplace
but uh as academics
we teach students
when we teach behavior change when we
teach things how should we uh actually
what what rules should we make for
ourselves to make sure that students are
because you talked about design thinking
design thinking moves very quickly
how should we be teaching
students how to approach these sorts of
problems
[Music]
well i think probably for example
stepping into the space of mental
mental health support which is the body
is much higher it's very hard to work
with those users
to to recruit them and i think you
shouldn't do it without working with
some medical medical staff as well so i
do work for interdisciplinary maybe work
with with on the other end people who do
have concerns but they are not at the
level of clinical significance
and i think that's a far more safer
space and at this time start working
with my phd student earlier on we don't
go into the space of depression straight
away try to go with people who have
who have mental well-being concerns and
you can have i mean it's not a black and
white we are going to continue all of us
and fluctuate
um i i would i would keep in this space
i think it's safer for them for us as
researchers they are also exposed to a
range of challenges i think we have to
be mindful of how mitigate those
uh our students have access to coaching
mentoring had access to
potential uh
counselling sessions if the content they
are unpacking the studies were was was
distressing them i think the
researcher's well-being is very
important and he'll be very carefully
nurtured
question about the human food
interaction uh study which i thought was
really really cool um i was curious why
you chose uh to evaluate it with
romantic partners
um instead of like
just other user groups what the
motivation behind that was
i think we wanted to move in from
self-regulation the space of
co-regulation
and
there there is a sense of some kind of
knowing each other and i actually i
worked with romantic couples before i
think it's an interesting space brings
up lots of things about emotion it it
allows you to dig deeper into the
emotional space that you wouldn't
otherwise so it wasn't just the food we
also interested in the emotional aspect
quite quite quite a lot that's why we
chose them to design these five flavors
and for home deployment we wanted some
interaction around them not just one
person so that allow us to see the
collaborative practices the household
rituals and i think it unpacked a little
bit more added social dimension a little
bit more
coming up on the hour so perhaps we can
have one more thank you
[Applause]